[Music]
in prison stripper news whose strategy
very bad idea
throw cigarettes submitted by your boy
Alex yeah boy
if I became a stripper in jail I'd
probably be really rich with my instant
noodles and cigarettes guards were
suspended from a high-security jail
after stripper showed up to entertain
the inmates you can't do a nice thing it
was lady strippers right they were hired
the guards hired the strippers this is
not an American see I knew it can't be
in America how did you know because I
keep watching stuff in the you know
those reality shows were they like
scared straight and those guys are not
punks they don't do [ __ ] for them even
the guards don't do [ __ ] for the for the
inmates though isn't that it's like hey
if you do this for me I got people on
the outside to give you money it depends
on prison prisons up you got fooled
around there for like 20 years and a
hella crazy and some crazy organized
crime yeah they've run [ __ ] locked up
Joe this is Joe so we should work all
over the world America's prison all top
prisons right now abroad I just there
was one in Arizona and everyone's
wearing I saw one upset when they were
uh it was I can South America or some
[ __ ] right and like the prison system
has their own society that they run oh
yeah yeah and so like the first day that
you come in you're the [ __ ] you gotta
clean all the [ __ ] barracks you got to
dump out all the poo and [ __ ] and pee
from the toilet and do that and after
you get your bearings a bit then you can
do your own thing
but it was some serious [ __ ] it was like
the guards don't even do anything they
just let them they just let them run
their own world and they come out she
looks like she's a wrestler they're so
happy
Boston us ten
that jumpsuit does he have tic-tac-toe
signs on his pants yeah it wasn't
Riddler pants no just it's just it's
text yeah I think it says the name of
the prison Oh Dan will like that seems
like it's just fun but see I don't like
this this should be a fun party I forgot
that they [ __ ] up - yeah so that's the
issue
yeah so that's why this prison it got a
lot of heat for it that's true if
they're all timeout they shouldn't be
playing video games yeah this prison
actually has some of the country's most
dangerous men those women are brave I
don't care how much they pay me I'm like
[ __ ] no because women have power maybe
they get lady boners would you see his
thing man if you give them [ __ ] like
that they might come to [ __ ] down if you
take it from them completely when they
get back out they can water [ __ ] yeah
I'm going try to steal if I knew there
was free strippers in jail I probably go
to jail for my purpose it's prison these
people I don't always say I want them to
suffer but if they did like heinous
crimes and this is a top-level prison I
mean these are the scum of the earth
this isn't like some regular like I
stole a car typists yeah when he dogs
dicks when it they hopped over the
fences they keep [ __ ] trying to milk
the dogs dick with [ __ ] common [ __ ]
Hey when you say dick dog bandit I
imagine someone robbing a bank with a
dog dick himself to with their face
they're just tongue just flops on the
side this whole thing it was part of an
event which was a rehabilitation project
to commemorate Youth Day which is the
day when dozens of protesting school
pupils were gunned down by police in
1976 mm-hmm and so that was this whole
day they were celebrating you two wait
it's a social justice event to
commemorate history and end up bringing
strippers they're saying that the
strippers weren't approved by the
proven that the police officers that
were involved in whoever brought these
women in did get suspended you know how
stupid like this doesn't make any sense
that's like hey today's like Martin
Luther King Day
let's get lap dances for the prisoners
now well this one was about cops gunning
people down a different image are bad on
that was they wanted to change the brand
II get it I get it
never say that South Africa is one of
the countries with like one of the
highest crime rates in the world because
apparently since 1994 500,000 people
have been murdered you know why cuz bi
worth is a making music right now every
time he does it people come together
he's a musician he was the one talking
about Kanye and like seeing Kanye oh I'm
going to Kanye's house ninja he looks
like a white guy that has like a Asian
fade from 2003 I get him at riffraff
makes the corner oh you're talking about
that group that was in Chafee II oh well
you said chappie I was so like I wasn't
a soul I was like he's not talking about
the robot movie I saw him at the Korean
spa didn't get to see his dick though
[Laughter]
yeah yeah the music's trippy but I
didn't hate it I walked past them and I
said I'm famous too
no you did it in my heart I said yeah
I'm famous too look at my dick Tim
doesn't know you but I do well I mean I
always sympathize because like when I
watched like Shawshank Redemption and
you see dudes that have been there been
in there for like 10 20 years then you
kind of feel like oh maybe they deserve
a little fun you know I'm saying so I
was like what if they killed your
parents
who is the main actor in Shawshank
what's his name
Tim Robbins so I saw him at Sundance
right but I got too nervous to say hi I
saw him twice first time didn't say [ __ ]
good because you don't even know his
name I blinked it right now but he's
tall as [ __ ] I did not know he's like a
giant second time I'll
say hi to him but I didn't commit so
what happened was I was a type of show
that and what I just hit the back of his
jacket he turned about his walkie I got
too nervous but I saw me along and I
shook her hand and I scared her so so
we're good God you scared I shook her
head and I done like overhead after that
like wow you are a creepy because I was
so happy to see her I held her hand and
she was like oh nice to meet you and
then when the conversations stop the
hand should be like oh - but the head
wouldn't let go and I just if you
remember me how's the guy that you have
the call the cops like awkward
interactions hip-hop store Brooklyn
project I bet you is that huh I texted
you right or something like that or told
you you're still my friend or or like
whatever and I was like oh that's Chris
Pratt well you know what I I'm not gonna
say hi cuz I know how it feels like when
fans come up to me but then I was just
not good you guys remember Kyla Pratt um
she was on that sitcom one-on-one oh
yeah she was in the Nutty Professor as
the daughter she was the young girl in
love and basketball right oh you know
yeah okay I didn't have cable TV
she's a pretty young black actress I
familiar with her IMDB yeah I guess
apparently I brought her IMDB is that so
anyways I actually didn't realize how
much I know about Cal Fire's all right
now dr. Doolittle dr. Doolittle what'd I
say
I saw her at the Galleria Mall one time
in Torrance
and this is when Jin was popping on 106
& Park and I was like oh gosh she looks
sexy i'ma go holler right so I walk up
and I'm like hey um I don't know I don't
know if you give Kelly prayer right she
was like she's like yeah yeah I was like
I don't know if you know me Jim 115 Park
and she oh yeah yeah that's right
okay well uh if you ever you know need
need need me for like this show
something like that you will get in
touch just let me know all right she's
like okay at least she's got you're a
normal person
that's cool she's like that was [ __ ] I
get so nervous when I see famous people
and then usually the people that I look
up to is like not what everyone really
knows like you know George Clinton from
the Parliament [ __ ] that's him - yeah
George clean from the Parliament
Funkadelic I was at the NAMM show and he
fell asleep next to me while we were
watching a performance so there was like
a violinist and he was like two seats
away and I was like oh my god that's him
and he's like a [ __ ] grandpa right
now so then afterwards I was like can I
shake her hand
he was like laughing at me like yeah and
I was like oh we met Kevin Love oh we
did well we didn't wait wait wait we
walked past each other
no I shook his hand remember and I
creeped him out - no cuz he was well I
have it on video I said hey man can I
shake your hands congratulations on the
ring bow and I was like we best friends
he laughed but he kind of looked pissed
so I didn't assume yeah you're weird
I remember that you know what it is like
I get I get excited about a couple
things so basketball players right and
also people that affected my childhood
so if it's like a new celebrity like
Chris Brown or whatever I don't give a
[ __ ] you didn't affect me like that
but the one yeah if I thought Bill copy
even you know touch me please
you got a couple of quaaludes the famous
person you met no collaboration oh it's
like asian-american thing right like and
I have all these people that are like
kind of like in the forefront
asian-american Entertainment Holly
whatever and they're not only give a
[ __ ] about you those people and then I
saw the the [ __ ] pushed in guy from
training day
another one the one that actually says
the line not the main job nobody's
around this guy nobody recognizes that
this Colo number two like dude I gotta
get a picture with that guy I got
pictures though awesome you're always
looking at him like you're like what's
your problem man what about your shape
Bush thing I got I got mad at
collaboration one year what cuz I went
like like two years ago and um they were
like okay now we're gonna have we're
gonna like play a real of all the Asians
who have you know been on like been
representing like this year like in the
meet in TV and movies and I'm watching
and it was like super obscure like many
parts that they were showing included in
this [ __ ] as well as like bigger parts
to you know I was watching and like the
whole thing went went on and I wasn't in
it and I was like oh I'm gonna TV like
for years funny I wasn't included in the
thing okay you're like one of the only
few youtubers that are asian-american
they've been doing this for a long time
that has been on TV for that long I
wasn't gonna say it but they even helped
me and we're like like hey you know we
we added you on the on the when we did
collaboration again we add you to the
things I've already insulted yeah which
is stupid name hey guys would you think
of that video I know you loved it so
make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos check it out up here
[Music]